There are dozens of frame works besides Bootstrap available,
Foundation 4 by Zerb and
Yaml 4 by Derk Jesse, provide huge sets of features comparable to Bootstrap.
You'll find everything from responsive grid systems and nice looking buttons, to
Javascript modules for interactive elements like drop down menus and carousels.
If you need simplicity other frameworks like 960 Grid, Susy and Frameless
provide their own grid systems without the overhead of additional features.
Bootstrap is currently one of the most popular frameworks and
actually that's why we're using it.
It does, however, include some advanced functionality you might never need.
The good news is that because it's so robust, after you've mastered Bootstrap
you'll be able to pick up other, simpler frameworks with very little effort.
To learn more about Bootstrap and
other frameworks, check out the links in the instructor's notes.